this is the moment Yemen's Houthi rebels
say they shot down a Saudi Air Force
fighter jet the rebels aired this video
on Saturday the Saudi UAE led coalition
confirmed one of its planes went down in
al-jarf government in the country's
northeast the Houthis also broadcast
vision of what it says is the aftermath
saudi-led air strikes in the area
followed which the rebels claimed were
retaliatory attacks the Saudi coalition
released a statement saying there was a
possibility of what calls collateral
damage to civilians this show you that
the Sanaa forces has been now able after
they have shut down the several of this
of Saudi or American drones over the sky
of Yemen in the last three months now it
seems to me that they are able to shoot
down those fighter jet and I can say
that if they start this stage this mean
that we're gonna enter a new stage of
the war the Houthis claim the plane was
downed with an advanced air-to-ground
missile some analysts say if that's true
it would be a very significant
development in Yemen's long-running war
this is a big deal knowing that already
they're partners the Yemenis sorry the
Emiratis you know how for all practical
purposes withdrawn left and now the
Saudis are there and an incapable of
finishing the war and certainly
incapable of winning the war and now
perhaps with this game-changer beginning
to lose the war the conflict in Yemen
has killed tens of thousands of people
and brought millions to the brink of
Furman it's estimated more than ninety
one thousand Yemenis have been killed
and another 3 million displaced by the
fighting there's no sign yet when it
will end
Nicola gage al Jazeera